man i didn't think
2022 was gonna start off this dope
but damn it didn't start off awesome
watch this
[Music]
that is a person who is very
enthusiastic about a twitter suspension
i'm not sure that i've ever seen another
human being as happy as that which means
that this person is really kind of sad
first of all good indicator this person
has bad judgment is that he has a poster
from the m night shyamalan movie signs
behind him i'm losing my mind that's a
that's an
odd movie pick but beyond that why are
you so excited about marjory taylor
green being suspended like i've never
been that's excited about anything
that's happened online ever in my entire
life and i spend half of my life online
wow